- [Voiceover] So we have
a circle right over here
and the first question we'll ask ourselves
is what are the coordinates
of the center of that circle?
Well, we can eyeball that,
we can see, look, it looks like the circle
is centered on that point right over there
and the coordinates of that point,
the x-coordinate is negative four
and the y-coordinate is negative seven.
So the center of that
circle would be the point
negative four comma negative seven.
Now let's say, on top of
that, someone were to tell us,
someone were to tell us,
that this point, negative
five comma negative nine
is also on the circle.
So negative five
comma negative nine
is on the circle.
So based on this information,
the coordinate of the center and a point
that sits on the circle, can
we figure out the radius?
Well the radius is just
the distance between
the center of the circle
and any point on the circle.
In fact, one of the most
typical definitions of a circle
is all of the points that
are the same distance,
or that are the radius
away from another point,
and that other point would
be the center of the circle.
So how do we find out the distance
between these two points,
between these two points?
So the length of that orange line.
Well we can use the distance formula,
which is essentially
the Pythagorean theorem.
The distance squared,
so if the length of that
is the distance, so we could
say the distance squared
is going to be equal to,
is going to be equal to
our change in x squared,
so that right there
is our change in x, and I
have to write really small,
but that's our change in x,
our change in x squared,
plus our change in y squared.
Our change in y squared.
Change in y squared.
Now what is our change in x?
Our change in x, and you
can even eyeball it here,
it looks like it's one,
but let's verify it.
It doesn't matter which one,
just use the start or the end,
as long as you're consistent.
So, let's see, if we view this as the end,
we'd say negative five
it'd be negative five,
minus negative four
And so this would be
equal to negative one.
So when you go from the
center to this outer point,
negative five comma negative nine,
you go one back in the x direction.
Now the actual distance would
just be the absolute value
of that, but it doesn't
matter that this is a negative
because we're about to square
it and so that negative sign
will go away.
Now what is our change in y?
Our change in y.
Well, this is the
finishing y, negative nine
minus negative seven,
minus our initial y
is equal to negative two.
And notice, just to go from that point,
that y to that y, we go to negative two.
So actually, we could call
the length of that side
as the absolute value of our change in y.
And we could view this
as the absolute value
of our change in x.
And it doesn't really matter
because once we square them
the negatives go away.
So our distance squared,
our distance squared,
I really could call
this the radius squared,
is going to be equal to
our change in x squared.
Well, it's negative one squared,
which is just going to be one
plus our change in y
squared, negative two squared
is just positive four.
One plus four, and so you
have your distance squared
is equal to five
or that the distance is equal
to the square root of five.
And I could have just called
this variable the radius,
so we could say the radius is equal to
the square root of five.
And we're done.